[Musique]
tu peux retirer 20 euros sepa je pense
qu'il peut retirer 20 euros sur un
livret a peut être les 80% sont pas cons
merci à tous oui tu sais ce qu'il te
reste à faire
[Musique]
céramique tapas l'impression des fois
que la vie n est pas ce qu'elles
semblent être
[Musique]
[ __ ] c'est quoi ces pages et ce après
il faut qu'on mette une réponse arabe m
tu sais pas je chéris fit il faut que je
trouve très bien mais n'importe quoi je
sais pas mais quand même ça n'est pas
non surtout pas je crois je sais quoi je
sais pas moi je passais toutes mes
avants c'est quoi un bon ok ok ok arrête
de nous faire chier connaissent t'es
sérieux et j'ai paniqué zurich un
monsieur le président monsieur le
président on a besoin de 13 sur ce coup
là ça fait de la même veine mais un
élément du doigt de riz parfait merci
[Musique]
[Rires]